anybody who eats an Oreo all together
though
is a monster I guess the question is who
doesn't love Oreo cookies they're the
best cookie I've only seen a picture of
it it does have like Oreo in the middle
covered in chocolate I hope it's big and
I hope they crunches I don't know what
milk of chocolate is I've never heard of
it it's the purple boy oh yeah I think
they're European
oh this is enormous is this for one
person who's like family size this is an
Oreo cookie palette like a plate that's
some good-ass chocolate this tastes like
okay yeah we'll just have a sack to
enjoy it's creamy
you got your crunch in the middle it's
like a really soft milky chocolate the
first bite I took actually hurt and
tooth back here why don't they sell Oreo
cream in jars
what no this is a lot for me this is
very rich you know the food is good when
you like sing a little tune
that's a lot that's a lot
yep they're gonna stocking seven
servings
this exceeded my expectations
by 110 percent Oreo you're done good I
like to dip cooking in teeth okay cut
that